robert spencer we're noticing more and
more banning of news sources that simply
report on the extreme bias towards islam
and against islamophobia is this trend
going to finally start getting better
i wish i could say it were but i don't
see any sign that it is going to get any
better uh the reality of the situation
is that for years the left and islamic
advocacy groups have stigmatized any
honest discussion of the motivating
ideology behind jihad terror as
islamophobic and now they're moving to
silence
that discussion
and so uh there needs to be a general
pushback against this as there needs to
be a general pushback against the left's
war on the freedom of speech altogether
and i'm still confident that will
materialize but so far it has not on any
large scale